hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chencences.com so in this video guys i
want to discuss what is happening on the
energy market we have oil price reaching
some crazy levels we have some breakouts
happening as well on some stocks related
to the energy sector so let's analyze
all of this and let's see what can
happen next let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys let me start with the crude
oil all right so cl one is the crude oil
futures i'm gonna here guys give you a
long term view this is something that
i've shared already in my discord a
couple of days ago so basically what is
the situation i'm here in the weekly
time frame this is a long-term view this
is 208 145 guys the maximum level
we had on the oil market i think it's
all-time high yes it is
and since then we are moving lower guys
right you can see
and here this is the beauty of technical
analysis once again guys is that we're
gonna use some very old price action and
it's gonna give us some very very good
information for what is happening right
now so look at this trend language okay
this trend line
that is connecting the highs that are
here
and then whenever you arrive
you know on this trend line you need to
find where is the consolidation and if
there is no consideration then the
breakout is not not good quality but
most of the time you're gonna have a
consideration even if it's a small one
so here you can see the past three weeks
guys we were consolidating below 92.5 so
this is the level i gave you guys all
right we can put that a little bit
higher
and
92.5 guys is the long term resistance
level that we've been consolidating
below for the past three weeks and last
week i mean four weeks because last week
we started to have the breakout we went
to 95 even 100 then pulled back and then
strong rally so this is a breakup guys
that is a good quality once again
because the trend line the resistance
trendline was
easy to spot thanks to this
consolidation
uh you guys know
where this is coming from is of course
coming from the conflict between russia
and ukraine because as you guys know
russia is selling a lot of gas to
european countries that
put in place some sanctions and saying
that they will no longer be buying this
gas i mean
a big part of it so they need to find
some other energies like gas oil to buy
to someone else so they're gonna
probably
increase the supply on the oil market so
this is the reason why the oil is the
oil price is going higher
so what can we expect from here whenever
you have this kind of breakout guys
usually what is happening is that we go
to the recent high okay so you need to
find the reason high where you have some
type of consolidation okay so here
it's pretty easy guys all right you have
you know
you can go from here
107
to here
and
i put this to 915 i've shared this as
well
i think on my discord guys
i'm not 100
sure
okay so 28 this was 28th of february
guys five days ago i had this level 114
all right we're at 95
and yeah i was saying that we would go
higher
i didn't post an alert guys because it
went too fast but i shared this analysis
in the platinum area whatever or i just
wanted to show you guys that you know i
didn't come up with the 115 level now i
have this level for a few weeks because
it's uh the recent high that i have here
so usually i'm coming to what i want to
i want to say to you guys whenever you
have this kind of breakout long-term
breakouts you reach the recent high you
have a rejection okay so we can expect a
rejection from here guys okay maybe a
little bit of consideration maybe a
small fake out we might go quickly to
120 level but then we're gonna probably
get rejected
and even maybe pull back find some
support here and then go higher okay
this is the typical breakout situation
and guys i'm explaining that very well
in my course that is released for the
past four days guys and you still have
50
discount in this course guys you will
learn so much you will learn exactly
what you need to pay attention to how
you should treat this kind of situations
where to get to take profits where to
enter how to manage your stop loss
everything is that i've been using
during my career as a professional
trader and it's going to help you to
generate consistent profits and if
you're not happy with it you get your
money back so just grab your calls guys
it's in the link is in the description
of this video and you're gonna love it
i'm sure of that so to come back to the
oil market here
are you gonna tell me yeah but i don't
see the oil price coming lower if the
tensions do not ease in the conflict and
the thing that might happen is right now
we have some
poor party in french you know so um
basically vladimir putin not himself but
his delegation and uh vladimir
zelinski are gonna discuss how to maybe
end this war you guys know that russia
is everywhere around chief right now so
my guess of course i i don't know at all
what's going to happen what's going to
come out from this
but is that maybe they're going to find
an arrangement i don't think so but at
least the market will think an
arrangement might be coming they're
going to be some discussions i don't
think that russia wants to
kill
everyone in kef i don't think it's the
best plan for vladimir putin so
my guess is that somehow
the markets is going to think that the
edge tensions would ease and if the
tensions is if there are some
negotiations of course in the
negotiations european countries will
reduce the sanctions if they reduce
their sanctions the oil price is going
to go lower so if
the market thinks that something is
going to come out from this negotiations
which i personally don't think but if
the market thinks so then the odd price
could um drop a little bit so i just
showed you guys how to associate
fundamentals with technicals so we come
on a resistance so the market is posing
and right now every good
news will be used
for
uh sellers to enter this trade and for
buyers to take profit so i think that
this is what we're gonna see and then
i'm afraid this conflict is only
beginning so we will probably go to 140
within the next year guys all right this
is a long-term view so i'm just telling
you that for the coming weeks i don't
see a real breakout of the 115 level i
think we're gonna uh go a little bit
lower find maybe some support among the
195 mark here it's of course a very nice
buying opportunity guys i'm gonna be
there to uh share this alert with you in
my discord and yeah then i think a
strong rally so quickly let's analyze
what kind of stocks you guys can use if
you're interested to get into this trade
we have some nice breakouts happening
guys on btu uh so btu is a stock uh that
is related to the energy sector so of
course it's uh going much higher uh with
this oil breakout i personally entered
this uh stock here guys around the 11
level because i had this reversal
breakout once again guys take my course
i explain exactly how to get into this
type of trades i got in here guys around
11.5 i had cool options i made
nice profits and i still keep a little
bit of my position here guys
uh and we can see that we have this
long-term breakout guys okay long-term
breakout same situation remember oil
with you you do a trend line on the
logarithmic scale guys important when
you check long-term prices uh
logarithmic scale and you manage to find
where is the consolidation and look guys
here the consolidation is here i mean
it's pretty obvious we get rejected
rejected so you see it's just important
i'll show you guys because if you put
your trendline like that i mean it's not
good you need to put it to get as many
reactions as possible in the past but
the most important thing guys is to get
the maximum number of reactions in the
very recent past in the consolidation
that is here that is telling you where
are the stop losses where are the
selling orders all right so now we are
going through this level brutally guys i
want to see volume increase this is a
weekly timeframe so we're going to check
that on friday but if we do have this
volume increase where do we going to go
guys we're going to have a breakout then
a recent high all right as usual
so let's try i didn't place it here
so we have here recent load that is
gonna make a resistance
and then the next one so those are the
targets okay guys so same thing i'm
already in this play but i'm gonna try
to
you know maybe increase my position or
do something i think we're going to the
35 area within one year right guys so
the breakout is not confirmed once again
because we're looking at a weekly time
frame then another stock guest that we
might be interested in nrp um we had
some success once again
in this uh stock in my discord at the
beginning of the year we bought uh here
guys at 22 we took profits around 30 so
we had this huge move up okay based on
breakout once again guys take the course
if you want to understand how to trade
those brackets properly guys with a good
risk management then what happened is
that we got rejected on this resistance
long-term resistance guys
same method as usual and look at what is
happening here this is what we call a
build up right this consideration that
is telling you where the resistance is
and we have this nice build up then
break out re-test and where do you think
we are going now guys we are going to
the recent high as usual guys the recent
high 44.
so my take is that we go here i wouldn't
buy now i don't have position in the
stock they don't do options so i didn't
get in and now it's too late to buy
because it can still re-test and then go
higher so it's too late to get in again
if you if you miss this one i think it's
too late b2 is still okay at the end of
the week uh once again i'm gonna post an
alert if i have the breakout confirmed
and here yeah we're probably going to go
to 44 and then let's see maybe
consolidate and if you have another
breakout you guys know how to play it
you wait for the consolidation you wait
for the breakout with volume increase
then you get in using the different
entry method that once again are
detailed in my course so if you guys
enjoyed this video please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to floor see you guys